hi i'm alvin and today i'm going to be
showing you how i came up with my recipe
for eight desserts in one sheet pan
when i try to come up with an idea for a
recipe what i really want to do is be
able to make people go like wow and
really show them something that they are
familiar with but maybe in a new way or
maybe something that is new to them but
in a familiar way it's always about
taking an element of something that
people know twisting in and making it
cooler making it different combining
with other things the end result is
doing people go wow that's sort of
usually the approach i take when i want
to really showcase food to people in a
cool way so for the eight desserts in
one sheet pan it kind of came from a
time where it was the holidays i'd seen
a lot of videos kind of pop up around
like you know desserts and baking and
pie and food network actually released
this one video that was pretty cool it
was like four pies baked in the same
sheet pan and to myself i was like wow
like that's really smart but can i take
it even a little further i know that pai
is just one dessert there are a lot of
desserts out there and a lot of baked
goods that people like to eat my hunch
was that around you know christmas time
or on the holidays usually at these
potlucks or parties there would be a
wide spread of desserts you know ranging
from cookies to brownies to cheesecakes
to pies i think this crazy idea came
about because in my head i was like man
what happens if you just kind of put all
those desserts together like is there a
way to take every single dessert that
everybody loves and turn it into just
one thing i think that's kind of how the
idea was born is i basically thought of
what can i use to serve this giant
dessert and how do i make sure that
everybody gets a piece they want because
sometimes when you bring a dessert to a
party not everybody likes brownies not
everybody likes cheesecakes but is there
a way to make sure that no matter who
you are at the party you're gonna have
one piece that's gonna speak to you and
that's how i sort of designed this eight
desserts in one sheet pan i wanted to
sort of build it in a way where if you
cut it in the precise manner you would
end up with just like a bunch of
different flavors you wouldn't really
cut it just along where the flavors met
but you'd be able to get pieces or bars
that would have two flavors three
flavors and the golden crown is when you
get that piece with all four flavors in
them the challenge with designing this
was that no matter what piece you get
the flavor should still go together so
you kind of have to play this weird like
math mix and match game of like do these
two flavors go together okay if this
goes together with this then this must
be next to here it was a lot of mean or
drawing things on a piece of paper and
crumpling it up like you do in the
movies and throwing it in the trash can
kind of restarting after a lot of trial
and error i managed to get a certain
layout of which desserts should go in
which area in the pan so that no matter
which piece you got it would always
taste great i'm super super proud of
this dish and i'd love if you would all
make it this year a lot of people are
intimidated by it and aren't sure if all
the desserts would bake together but
actually i was able to make it on my
first try and i really think you could
too and just really customize it how you
want if you do make it hit me up slide
in my dms throw me a little pic oh god
that sounds so weird if you do end up
making it i want to see how you
customize it hit me up send me a dm show
me what you got oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you